what do you think the best song of the
year is what would you say i don't know
i don't listen to a lot of pop music
but there was a great music video that
came out just the other day though it
was really good
i think it was a version of please come
home for christmas i really liked it i
loved the way it sounded
maybe that but if that's not the best
song of the year what do you think would
be
well according to npr taxpayer-funded
national public radio the greatest song
of the year
you already know npr it's wap it's wap
wet piece wet genital
structure i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
say the name of the song
whap is the song of the year by cardi b
uh npr described this because
they said that it mocks the insecure
the zealots the moral grandstanders
uh for having the audacity to uh push
back you know
it it mocks people who are
conservative it has feminist leanings
now i've never met any moral
grandstanders
more grandstanding about their morality
than the left
right the lie that they push is that
they're not
you know religious they're not uh
creating a moral framework they're just
they're just doing what works it's all
of us crazy christians
and jews and muslims we're the ones who
have these kind of crazy bible thumping
morality right but
the left doesn't do that they just have
science no they they have their own
religious understanding of the world
their own moral framework and their own
moral grandstanding
and if whap is the song of the year then
that is representing a very different
moral framework than the one that we've
traditionally had
do we have the hoods but do we have the
spine to stand up and say that one's
wrong
the old moral framework is right do we i
don't know here's one way we could show
that
defund npr either actually there are two
things the
first thing that would be good to do is
to take it over if i were president
today what i would do is i would use
all of the power that i had at my
disposal to
replace the executives at national
public radio
and put in people who understand things
and who understand that
whap is not the best song of the year
and then i would totally transform
national public radio and make it
actively defend the old conservative
standards and if i couldn't do that if
for whatever reason
corporate structure the law if i
couldn't do that you know what i would
do i would defund it i would tear it
down
it is not enough for us to throw up our
hands and say oh well that you know look
that's npr for you you know that's the
new york times that's the entire
mainstream media that's big technology
that's hollywood
that's the universities that's lower
education that's the bureaucracy well
that's the whole country
that's the whole country and if you
throw up your hands
you've given up the entire country
and we don't want it this sort of thing
has an effect i think for far
too long conservatives have tried to
pretend that the private realm
has no bearing on the public realm
the left understands this way better
than we do when they said in the 70s the
personal is the political they
understood that the way that people
interact privately
on the whole is going to affect how we
how we interact publicly
and that's true you've got npr saying
whap is the song of the year this
this song that you know they they say
it's uh wonderful for women it's
empowering
it's not the song actually says that
women are prostitutes the only way
to convince a man to marry you is to
become
uh to play the role of a prostitute the
only way to keep him engaged is to put
on different wigs so that he can
think he can convince himself that he's
actually cheating on you with another
woman
so that he remains aroused
that is not empowering ladies cardi
cardi give me a call that is not
empowering
but that has effects in a broader
[Music]
[Music]
culture